okay i burned my foot very badly
on my foreman grill and i now need
someone to come and bring me into work
you burned your foot on a foreman grill
i enjoy having breakfast in bed i like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since i don't have a butler i have
to do it myself so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill
then i go to sleep when i wake up i plug
in the grill
i go back to sleep again then i wake up
to the smell of crackling bacon it is
delicious it's good for me
it's perfect way to start the day today
i got up i
stepped onto the grill and i clamped
down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
what does this do
would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless
yes please
another please
sir is there a problem i'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
i i don't think i can give you any more
i want one
okay we're all set up in there mr
peralta just uh sign here
what's all set up what's going on ah
thank you for asking terrence
you see the food in prison was inedible
all i thought about day and night were
the things i wished i was eating and you
amy i thought about you a lot sex with
you just
us doing sex with foreplay great safe
babe thanks and so i decided to make my
food fantasy come true
unbutton your pants and take off your
shoes cause there's gonna be a
doink load of sodium at freedom feast
2017.
we begin where all great stories begin
in the quaint little town
a french fry village after that we're
gonna move our adventure over
to cheeseburger mountain which consists
you guessed it of
turkey burgers i'm kidding it's
cheeseburgers this is kind of just
stuffing you can avoid that but
it's attached to the thanksgiving turkey
theme cause i was thinking about that a
lot up in the jail
and finally we have a big old passover
brisket cause you know i loves my mom
if you would all take a seat while i
make a toast
kindly raise your two liters to freedom
to you and most importantly to orange
frank
and sex with amy to sex with amy sorry
should have said that last part
kevin you're such a gourmand i cooked my
way through julia child's cookbook
and now i'm halfway through the twilight
cookbook last night
i had edward's cornflake chicken
pregnant pam and i we get hungry at the
same times
so we've been eating together a lot not
all meals
just second breakfast lunch
second lunch and first dinner i thought
that maybe we should
do something special for early dinner
one
last ultra feast hmm
that sounds great what are you thinking
i think it should be a surprise
oh wow it's almost time for ultra feast
oh where's kevin
what you want to eat cat food with kevin
and not go to the hospital
that's fancy feast ultra feast is
something they made up so they can peg
out together in the name of ceremony
what is oktoberfeast there's no rush to
get to the hospital
i'm fine i'll get
and if i don't get there i don't get
there
our ultra feast menus theme
hollywood we have ratatouille
from ratatouille and tandoori chicken
from born into brothels
i tried to bake a cake like that
district nine prawn thing
but i are you okay
um okay let's begin the barbecue
oh hey little guy hey what are you doing
oh no
everyone meet your meat oh oh
no why are you doing this to us well in
my opinion not enough people have looked
their dinner in the eyes and considered
the circle of life
this is your dinner his name is tom
burn seriously no i understand that it's
hilarious but that is his given
christian name
tom is very smart and incredibly loyal
he's basically a dog
a dog we're going to cook chew and
swallow dude there's
kids around here good point which one of
you youngsters wants to help me drain
the blood from this animal
if you do a good job i'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
play ball
hey ron you're not gonna slaughter that
pig here are you
not to worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want
where is everyone who knows maybe they
finally figured out clam chowder is
disgusting because it's basically a
savory latte with bugs in it
this diet is very scientific sir all the
meals are pre-planned and delivered to
your doorstep
this is our breakfast an orange wedge
three cashew nuts
and a solitary grape it's actually more
than you realize
sometimes i can't even finish all the
grape well this seems unnecessary to me
you're all in perfect shape
you can always be healthier sir and i
like the challenge
plus it's good team building we're gonna
get through this together
hey guys pro tip lick the baggie
there's food molecules in there oh
that's so smart
that guy wanted to buy you a drink
really
i already have a drink do you think
you'd buy me mozzarella sticks
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait i worry what you just heard
was
give me a lot of bacon and eggs what i
said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
oh i'm usually more of a chocolate guy
but this one's closer so i'm gonna
do that ha ha spicy cake wine that's
habanero pepper frosting
because our marriage is going to says
all
unless you think it's a bad idea no
sounds like a great idea oprah 2
1. hold on there you
go let me get more of them shrapnel easy
yes exactly and you deserve a perfect
world
did you fill your bra with shrimp
no yes whatever
it's freaking heaven i'm sure they have
plenty of shellfish
i enjoy government functions like i
enjoy
getting kicked in the nuggets with a
steel-toed boot
but this hotel always serves
bacon-wrapped shrimp that's my number
one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food i'd go to a banquet and honor those
somali pirates
if they serve bacon wrap shrimp excuse
me
i humbly place before you my east meets
west patented traeger turkey burger
an asian fusion burger made with willow
farms organic turkey
a toasted tile cheese crisp papaya
chutney
black truffle aioli and micro greens on
a gluten-free brioche bun
enjoy this tastes as delicious as
beyonce smells
mmm i'm guessing what is this in here
saffron
wow somebody's got a sharp palate i love
the umami flavor
stop being so pretentious kyle sorry
here's mine it's a hamburger made out of
meat
on a bun with nothing add ketchup if you
want
i couldn't care less
ron i'm so disappointed i thought that
you and i were going to have a real
challenge never mind this is better way
better
kyle sorry andy ron's is better damn it
kyle
hmm oh my god so much better it's crazy
turkey can never beat cow chris
sorry well i don't understand i i've
tinkered with this recipe for years
granted it's been a long time since i've
had hamburger
this is better the commissary will
continue to strip
horrifying artery-clogging hamburgers
you